welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm really excited to be joined by two
founders in Kevin Tyler and rich
Bartlett who are the founders of consult
energy which is an energy utilities and
renewables recruitment agency that
operate in the UK US and looking to
expand the mainland Europe and there's
seventeen people in their business
currently and they're based out of
Birmingham rich Kevin thanks for joining
me remotely today no problem nice to see
you yeah it's like was always always
enjoy having sort of two founders
together on the podcast I think this
adds an interesting dynamic I don't know
you guys are keen to share that you guys
have known each other for a lifetime and
we're I always like to start this
podcast chats rich let me come to you
first how how did you guys get into
recruitment how did rich enter the the
world of recruitment yeah I mean he's
very clichéd and I've heard it a number
of times on your podcast that you know I
just fell into it that is slightly true
I've always gravitated toward sales
roles okay and I got to the age of 23 I
think it was and I'd always done sales
of some kind I remember first sales job
believe it or not I sold I sold pies
down Villa Park just say very
successfully my yard yeah thank you
thank you so one side I'd be said in a
villa park my big Villa fans the next
side I would be sending this at Andrews
which is where our archenemies
Birmingham City play yeah and I remember
one one time quite vividly I was walking
with my pies to my standing spot in in
st. Andrews which is right at the edge
of the peach and the strap on my box
broke and all my pies just drop boom and
all of the fans I don't know there might
have been about six or seven booming
City fans there because I don't get many
fans we started singing who dropped all
the pies but yeah so that was an
interesting experience but yeah I've
always been themselves and went
travelling
and I was in Australia and there's a guy
actually that runs a recruitment
business that they carry and I not and
he spoke about recruitment and I've
never heard of this this crazy world of
recruitment and that you essentially
sell people into businesses and then
when I got home from traveling I think I
just turned Kevin's got a bad memory
than me so now they just turned 24 June
22 23 and my TV online and you know i
taked a load of the boxes here cuz I
know graduate caliber sales experience
etc etc been traveling so had some life
experience coaching America all those
things and yet never knew rhetorics
existed and until that day when a load
of them contacted me and yeah got sent
to a number of interviews find a company
that I really wants to work for and
never look back really okay cool and
then keV what about you what how how's
the Kevin's story differ and well I mean
I actually have a little brief flirting
with recruitment actually before we went
travelling so when - I don't give a win
that we were gonna go travelling I
thought but I get a job and make a bit
of cash so I call around a few companies
and yet in the Yellow Pages somebody
younger listen it'll be like what's that
and the first one I spoke to was
recruitment company I was called a
maximum six pound our call centre job
for like two or three months and the
lady went hang on I was 13 grand a year
whoa let's talk about it so an Achon end
of doing industrial recruitment for what
two guys shifting tires on a factory so
I don't we came out of first recruiting
job so yeah my situation be different I
went to uni briefly but I am I've had a
holiday rep when I was 19 I work for
Club 1830 and where did you where I
think two seasons in Cabos I did want
Amalia and I did then I traveled for a
year with rich and coach foot mayor
Allen you you're a veteran mate I did
two seasons in magaluf not not for like
a company or anything just selling
tickets on the street for a bar or my
first sales job
this was hardcore and then I came up and
travelling on bits skin in the summer I
thought hmmm I'm gonna do to make some
money so I did a four season in wagons
auntie Wow and
you meet anybody that's ever done record
and if I've been you threaten particular
1830 back in the day they'll say is the
hardest job probably bar ministry you'll
ever do yeah you know I've kind of
changed as I've got older you know I can
you know I understand obviously the
world's a bit different so expectations
be different but god I remember doing 52
hours straight three ones working like
straight through and you just sent you
just sell him right getting people to
yeah they might sell him packages and
stuff I first when I thought I'd do up
up great I get to you know to you know
have a few free drinks and party for a
few years I realize very early on it's a
hardcore sales job yeah actually I think
if you remember the TV show Club reps
that was out about 20 years ago the only
one that I remember is that [ __ ] what's
it called
it had that imaging I can't remember
it's good but yeah oh one of the
uncommon shows magnet yeah something
like that yeah well anyway that they did
a TV show about it itv2 about 20 years
ago the lady that was the boss on that I
mean collar aki who is my boss seen
before when i thought she was quite
actually anyway she was she was very
much you know if you were good at sales
you did well if you weren't good at
sales based you know you never meet you
know the only can you be gone so i
didn't really quite hardcore sales so
excursions selling trips and then came
back did my last bit of traveling so I
did last bit of rep in me and went out
on a well back in the UK with 23 which
just you know me which is really cool to
the bright lights of Birmingham probably
to the dome and I won't put my CV online
and not in Rome what I know now top
salesperson in Greece and blah blah blah
I woke up in the morning on Richards
floor not even not even on his so I
didn't like him that much
I think he's dad had brought me a
sausage sandwich so you know it's a bit
of a bit of rest boy anyway and I don't
hate 82 missed calls from my phone and I
just called the first rep to reckon yeah
all right so let's just frame art for
everyone then so then the both of you
ended up in different recruitment
companies and pretty much did like
forward to a four to five year stint in
one company from what I saw on LinkedIn
in different businesses and then and
then just for everyone listening context
and after that you then obviously
started consult energy which has been
going for like 10 10 years now business
you
he start off as consult solutions so it
was more of a generic IT recruitment
agency and we we started working with a
number of clients in the energy space or
the utility space and realized quite
quickly that there was we were never
going to be the greatest IT recruiter on
our on our road that we were based on
that alone in the UK although there was
a real opportunity to create some
especial in the utility space and it was
you know it's it's a market that people
can't be without so okay cool so just
quickly then let's just touch on you
guys being employed and working for
someone else as quickly so where you got
what what gave you guys the confidence
to start your own recruitment business
during your sort of four or five year
period yeah we had quite different
experiences in in some ways outreach
work for company which was team
commission model yeah actually that rich
that's mental me if that's not the first
well you had that collaborative I guess
then you know the s3 model was initially
yeah okay so what what gave you the comp
like why do what gave you the confidence
start around business well I don't think
it was ever on my radar from totally
honest okay I'm probably one definitely
more risk-averse than Kevin is and went
into to ven group who great goods work
for and I opened the Birmingham office
with five or six other consultants and
we just when a and just created a brand
in Birmingham and I love the fact that
nobody knew we were there companies knew
we were coming after their their
business my Tommy phone was always been
just opening new teams and just breaking
into new markets and I just love that
under creating something and winning
something now then you were for a big
company there's a big name there for
clients why don't want to work with you
or clients do work with you and yeah you
you right you know looking back I'm
gonna load more money I just absolutely
you don't you didn't oh I guess Kevin
with a light to fill you in the walk and
sort Commission II was getting but it's
some people don't know that
oh god yeah yeah and you know options
and then to be fair I was paid pretty
well you know I better pay rises and the
Commission wasn't that bad and it was
consistent so yeah there was sermons
where keV was like look what I got paid
in other months ways that I think it
paid as much as yeah yeah no he's rough
with this movie and I don't I saw my
career going on with a group for a
number of years and until we were
Edgbaston one day watching the cricket
and Kevin it'll jump into his experience
with progressive and what led him to
this point just kind of like bent my ear
with a little bit over do you want to
start a recruitment business yeah I
couldn't find a reason to say no I don't
we just say I think the exact phrases
after a few points was I'm gonna start
an agency actually join Minh if you
don't you an idiot
[Laughter]
it took a few more conversations you
know just trying to understand why you
look like and then I remember going to
my mom and dad and my dad's like hugely
risk-averse they'll put a stop to this
yeah and you know they might save me
from what could be a huge mistake I mean
he obviously wasn't and my mom and I'm
like because how old is you at that
point
27 yeah just let what's the worst that
can happen
yeah usually the worst that could happen
was that I wouldn't get to work with the
people in that office that I'd grown you
know you know over a number of years and
now that was it I'd be a better
recruiter for the experience
yeah a better employee for the
experience so yeah we went for it
yeah I'm a big believer in you'd rather
regret doing something I'm not doing
something and I'll be quite honest was
never on my radar to do it myself
yeah the the experience so I had a
progressive was was incredible and I'll
highlight to anybody that that would
speak to me anymore if you speak to any
one else that's ever to s3 they've got a
lot of things to say some negative but
probably like positive the office I
worked in the Birmingham office in
peered for a 2004 to 2006 was was
unbelievable I mean like the world what
made it unbelievable so it was just it
was just the collective belief and
mindset and attitude that everybody had
so I'm looting arrows it was quite weird
actually as well again in turn my
experience of the whole rep direct
contacting me yeah I went to four
interviews I interview with Biz then and
if
the companies and I was pretty set on
working for a company and it was
Eddington erector recomment listen I'm
gonna get in trouble if you don't go to
this last interview please go to it and
that ended up being progressive so it
was like man he did the kind of the
puppy-dog clothes and that's pretty got
me to go to it but I just fell in love
with it because there was only provide
links with there was a guy I'm still
make to know he he'd also coached
football in the states there was yeah I
had also been a colony rare and what I
loved about it most was that it was very
much a case of like you believe you
could be doing what you wanted to do and
I was think the collective attitude that
office had was that and some of the
numbers of that we did quite as wise
compared to peers and even I reckon our
own business or wack side of it was just
was crazy what I mean called probably
not the world's greatest consultants
were doing you know three deals a month
fairly regularly
mmm and I think that that goes out to my
boss you know John was a really great
guy and you know and you know fostered
an environment of sort of you know push
it you know like happen so I really had
a great grounding in that nearly I like
a lot of people it took me a bit of time
to get up to speed in recruitment
I didn't didn't do a deal for five
months yeah I mean I wasn't allowed to
were even like a job I had to basically
pull 15 jobs and all that to be at 20
percent and you know are these only
white board on the wall acts and not one
off every time I'm in the Midlands it
ought to be an infrastructure and I
remember when rich and I lived together
at this point and he was on probably
three four K year more than me getting
team commission and I was on the balcony
one night going anyway talk to you rode
you taught me range and thing we're
watching the contender on TV anyway fast
for a few years I don't you know I moved
very quickly to manager and did some
really big months of deals and had lot
successes of both that can sort another
managing an office in Leeds and I think
as the company moved towards or just
post when they when they floated
I just felt the whole sense of them
looking at what what made me notice it
was when normally when people leave off
and you'd be like who's left are they
weren't great they you know yeah it
should really good pillow fight leading
live in yeah and I thought hang on a
minute like you know there's something
going on here and it was the mid of the
recession and I just thought you know
what like I know what I'm doing now I've
run offices having teams I've done you
know every aspect of the job and
I think I'd like to give it a shot and
then I realize I think where you want to
be on my own so okay cool so I guess I'm
sure you you've had conversations and
people think about stander and
recruitment business or spoken to other
business owners or whatever but I mean
the conversations that I have the the
biggest fear is the first year right so
I guess obviously great thing is that
you two knew each other really well so
you've got that innocent trust there and
confident you guys will have each
other's back right but what what was the
game plan for that year one like how did
you plan to differentiate yourself and
what was the game plan for you or your
own recruitment business though there
wasn't a game plan really how do we
survive we both put five grand on the
table I mean right now just see what we
can do it is and we didn't play
ourselves for probably about first 1415
months and we bought tuned up top and
two mobile phones and just the rawness
of it's us versus the world now and we
can only survive on the ability that we
have to do recruitment and it helped as
you say that we were you know really
really close Kevin move down from Leeds
and we lived in you know house together
in a suburb of Birmingham and everywhere
you looked in this high is it was just
white boards with stuff about jobs and
we had a third housemate blessing my Ely
was really good and he actually he know
works for us since so he didn't at the
time and he only joined what 15 months
ago he was there at the start of our
cycle sort of solutions they were there
any dinner and we're not updating
whiteboards and sending CV so he got
quite crash course in in recruitment and
you know what there wasn't a game plan
you know we could enough we can do this
and it probably wasn't a game plan for a
good number of years not that we were
playing but running a business but you
know did you want it to be just more
than new T or was it was that the first
of a match and I mean was it I think we
fell into that initially saying that the
plan was necessary to be live style but
because we both could you know build
relationships what we did was we had a
few clients we built relationships with
and that was what we didn't really
require three or four clients we did a
lot of business with and it was greater
than once you know things change there's
a change of procurement in one business
there's a sector change in another
business and they don't drop off we
realise we
probably strategize a bit more diverse
and that was the point really we looked
we looked at an energy Newton it is but
I'm gonna briefly go back to those early
days I'm see Apple is embracing work
from home there yeah you know there's
all these videos go man Iraq zoom and
what happens in interruptions
I remember we we did this for probably
six six probably maybe nine months till
we got our first little office off our
first ever deal that we did obviously
the sink in putting a none of its how
longs it take you I mean dealing the
first week and absolutely nailed on oh
god it was dead we are member to the
pocket test goes and I was like about a
month in with the random job like a
validation tested in middles brother who
knows anyway
kind of find someone so I did it and I
remember I was in an old football shirts
washing up with the washing machine next
to me plates triangle in you know and
and then did a 7 kg and I thought
hanging a minute we celebrating with his
cigar the local weather things did you
go in just to help me out so then did
you I know obviously it seems like
organically you saw the opportunity and
utilities and things like that but like
so the the market you originally went
into was that in the market that you as
in richer that then group all right no I
did I say richly fine okay we don't we
don't we need IT in finance yeah yeah so
you started with that okay cool so then
I guess okay that's interesting then so
basically just the mentality was let's
just let's just make [ __ ] happen
basically yeah you know we were just
responsible for the activity that we put
in Dane day we had no grand plans around
making it X or while what would happen
after two years or four years because
the reality is you gotta get past month
one and then you don't get past month
three and then you've gotta get to month
12 before you can start thinking about
you know two and we spoken to a lot of
you know we part of networks of
recruitment owners and yeah talk to
people and most plans go out the window
because now you you're not dealing
reality and the problem that we found
and you know we eventually got some
helping we've worked with non-executive
directors for the last few years and we
great or what would be great and we
don't know what we don't know and if
someone can give you a map and go these
are things you're gonna have to
experience in your three
year five and year seven then if you
have if you're gonna set up a business
get someone that can give you that map
ability alone is not enough because we
have an ability to be good at
recruitment not the ability to run a
business because we are no idea about
corporation tax about you know annual
returns about XYZ and I think though
there were times where we've never got
to a point where we thought one it's not
this on the end we've never even got to
a point where we've you know had such a
bad quarter where we thought is it is it
worth it we've always backed our own
ability and also had relationships have
brought success but there have been
times where you know it's it's just like
way back to wave after wave of stuff you
just got a deal with them that only gets
harder when you recruit stuff because
you would you know I think what can I've
been guilty of in the past and will
never change is we get really close to
our staff so my partner or you know an
evening you know who you on the phones
who I was so and so I tell you about
this and just like hey why you even that
close to them how do you know about that
and she's she's an accountant so she's
never worked in a sales environment
letting on in recruiting environment but
I think a recruitment business only the
ones are either the two I work for a
very tribal yeah it has each other's
back and maybe that's something that I
brought across from from vein group
being a team commission or maybe that's
something that Kevin brought across from
being a brilliant progressive office and
it's surprising sometimes when you meet
people that have worked in recruitment
so long and they've never had that kind
of tribal feeling they've never you know
wanting to run into the trenches and
battle with their colleagues whereas I
think in recruitment you get that so
Kevin I can get quite close to our staff
and be there 24/7 for them where
actually we probably should take a bit
more this step back sometimes and look
any strategically rather than my getting
things all right so I guess just to help
me out then so was it what the first
look what two three years it was just
that mentality of just get up and go
make [ __ ] happen and then what and then
was it the you till it's like when the
things start changing the money a lot
yeah we we hide someone well here and
there in the first after party about a
year or so and classic sort of situation
we find a lot of people and some are
okay some weren't great
in a small office and back back in the
Birmingham and you know I think when
you've got four people and if one each
team isn't particularly pumped to do
recruitment then you've that's quite a
percentage II workforce isn't great
yeah when you've got 50 people if you've
got one or two in the path great so we
we just kind of kept going in terms of
winning relationships and looking after
most clients but we inadvertently won a
few energy relationships those energy
relationship strained became quite big
and then we made decision probably about
five five four five years ago to go
right let's stop playing at listener and
this is well so everything we've been
through puts it in a brilliant position
now because we've got those those those
sudden you know lines on the tree you
know we've got no experience and we look
to what we're doing with stock actually
right let's look at our clients there's
a few finance as if you read some it
quite a few in utility space and said
right let's put all our eggs in the
utilities basket
hmm and and that that then it be kind of
real scene yeah do so was that decision
just form from because you recognize
that you're doing more business with
them and yeah like okay yeah yeah credit
weights do I know you've spoken to one
of our guys will farm their podcast in
the past he just wouldn't shut up about
it and it's his market yeah and and you
know the eggs in the basket at that
point was right we'll use you start our
utilities team and look after that and
and then it just snowballed and yeah how
did that how did that because I think
I've seen you're part of all these
network creature was here sort of an
inch wide mile deep and it seems that
obviously took a couple years to
recognize where you want to put eggs in
your boss it so how how did that how is
that then impacted your business having
a real focus it's been incredible isn't
it really I think it I mean the the
level of experience I had at progressive
progressive eastern edge himselves has
been you know most of the foot seen
that's great but actually might beat up
one office in London did one place it
was one one member that's one hundred we
can say quite safely that I'd say almost
two hundred people in the only energy
utility space we were with yeah and
actually when you're when you're so
niche in that area people get to know
who you are
then organically that just grows I've
never had the level of relationships
I've gotten and we've got as a business
now that I had in five years nearly five
years of progressive yeah I cookie is so
neat rather than doing you know even
though you've got consultants at this
specific bits of their market
essentially you are a
fairly generic company you might split
it off but it says what we do you know
all the consultants a lot of the
consults have got the same clients even
if they're doing different bit bits bits
of the market which is it's crazy so
people just don't know who you are and I
think it's really given us that that
foothold into it into doing a bit more
business with with obviously the same
client because they will you know you
are yeah of course so so when you
recognize the when you look to your
clients and you saw the utilities piece
then what what what them was the game
plan then so did it was it where you
just really back to will and said okay
look off you go and we'll support you
well we'll help you make it happen and
then yeah pretty much overnight we took
a load of generic IT consultant and said
you doing utilities yes some of them
left yeah yes some of them right you
know put a brave face on and then stuck
around and then got new jobs in the net
and that was fine no now as a business
owner you need people that will follow
you into battle you need people that
would trust your decisions and I
remember sitting on the cabinet and
going look we've got this generic IT
team that are doing X amount of business
and we've got a couple of guys and
utilities that doing three hundred
percent more business and they're not
Messi and Ronaldo they're not average
Premier League players there's gotta be
some gymnast and then we adapted an
assist scheme so you know people get
their individual Commission right but
you can benefit from what your
colleagues are doing by recommending
candidates and getting a split of the
fee and okay and passing jobs cause the
Kevin mentioned that I can sort of work
with the same clients well if Lily's
doing the day apart which she doesn't
and Joseph in operations well if Josie
pulls a job in the same crier and passes
across in Lille well Joseph gets
rewarded for that so you know every
phone call that leaves our business is
it is either a call to a client that
could benefit a number of people in the
business or a phone call to a candidate
that could benefit a number of people in
the business yeah and yet we lost some
people and you know people didn't agree
with the decision we made and you know
what that's fine all make decisions in
the future that people won't agree with
of course though
and we have we had to live with that
real it's and look at some of the losses
and go right for the great of good this
is the right move mmm so so what when so
what went on in the first couple years
then when you made
decision and what surprisingly we quite
quickly won a lot of clients only we did
some analysis the other day and came in
touch on on a number of client that we
were I think we've had over a thousand
vacancies given to us within the utility
space over the last three years and you
look at some of them and you can see
where we maximize the opportunities and
others where we've made and what and
deal with one client and then they're
just gone off the radar for radar for
whatever reason so it was it was just a
case of trying to understand who did
what and like anything right if you go
and speak to someone who sure about
doing a podcast and you tell them that
you've done podcast with X consulting
and y consulting Zed consultant then
you're going to get their interest
because that's read ability and
experience here so when we pick up the
phone and we work with X energy company
and why did you company then people will
listen to us and and we have a bit more
credibility and unfortunately well
unfortunately at the time there was a
lot of growth in the sector and now
there's been a bit more volatility with
businesses going out of business for
whatever reasons yeah but we've got a
really good brand and the energy sector
doesn't start and end with with an
energy supplier so there's lots of
companies that we now work with where we
could probably I know we mentioned that
we're in the US and we're going to break
into you we could probably just only UK
but for us it's about looking at the
skill sets that we recruit for and
utilizing the relationships that we've
got with candidates that go out to other
parts of the world and work with with
clients in in those areas okay so I
guess just to sort of finalize the sort
of beginning part of your business then
I guess know what you guys know now what
what how would you do things differently
if it to start consulting as your
tomorrow or what advice would you give
yourself do you think for people looking
looking at taking that leap good
question God gave you can shoot this one
first and that is a really good question
and I think the things we do differently
initially when we do consult solutions
would be policy a bit nisha a bit
earlier that's when we start to sort
energy I think the biggest issue I think
we've had we've certainly seen before in
terms of getting close to people that
work for us you know I'm in a great
position and I'm sure ritual shared it's
that you know particularly everything
happened recently with the whole clomid
thing where I know some companies made
some some you know some pretty harsh
and I'm sure some another justify
masseur probably wasn't but there's
known in our business that we did want
to be in our business yeah I don't think
that many people that can say that in
terms of you know having 17 staff at
every single one of the man's value yeah
but in the past I think we've probably
been guilty have been probably a bit too
kind to people and actually we probably
could have been a bit I think
swiftly with some of our decisions of
people you know we've always had a sense
of thing we're rich and I above you get
a consultant that's got a bit of ability
we think if but it's not been quite
perfect we think we'll fix him yeah come
work for us well we know we'll give them
the white kind of you know guidance and
doesn't always work out and actually
some people we've probably been a bit
too kind to and that probably doesn't
send the best message to others in the
business I think in the last two years
we really recognize that and we're a bit
more robust with our recruitment process
now and I think that that's kind of
yielded it's a real success what we've
had so what my advice but you can't be
afraid to make those tough decisions
when they're a smaller business and you
say you moved to people I mean there's
only six of you you've just got rid of
yeah I know you mean yeah I mean that I
was in the business of that size and
like it's when you have like so like if
I work for you guys early on and I have
direct access to you guys you are in the
business it's so easy just to form like
real because you really are as you said
going to battle each day of each other
and it's it's hard yeah I totally get
that and that's difficult isn't it so I
guess okay interesting rich anything to
add to that from your perspective what
anything to start today with no
knowledge of what we've gone through but
someone just give me a little bit of an
advice I would want to be told
get someone alongside you a
non-addictive director that's been there
and done it yeah because you gotta know
what you're good at and you've also got
to know what you not do that so that
would be my you know reach out to
someone and there's lots of people out
there that you know will want to invest
or want to develop a business or
whatever it might be but just get
someone that can give you that bit of
roadmap and secondly might know what
you're really good at and stick to it
and don't try and do everything so again
something that we've been going in the
past he's having a list of 15 things
that we're trying to fix all the time
but actually it's not possible no you
end up doing it in a little bit of each
one and then in three months time you
look back and go
why didn't that improve so yeah it's
it's easy to say with hindsight yeah cuz
but yeah and I'm sure there'll be people
that have been on this podcast and
people that will be on this path us
because it would be experience different
things and therefore have made different
mistakes it will give you different bits
of advice but yeah you know people start
recruitment business is because they
think they're good at recruitment and
that's totally fine but know that that
doesn't necessarily mean you couldn't
run in a business and the skills that
I've had to train myself in and skills
that Kevin's had to Train himself in as
well because no one else is gonna do it
no one's coming to save us no it's just
the case of being in a situation where
you get a good Network around you you
you you know you hire slowly and your
fire fast but also when you do hire you
give people that you believe in the
right landing the right runway and the
right support to be able to be
successful because not everyone you know
I've heard a number of times that you
did have the best start to your
recruitment and that's enough but that
doesn't make you a horrific recruiter or
a bad person so it's about picking the
right personalities that work well in
your business but trusting the decision
that you once made to recruit them and
if they're delivering the activity like
doing all you can to give them that
opportunity as well yeah cool
so always talk about on this and I think
it's it's one of the biggest challenges
and one of the main things that a lot of
people mention me about from a business
owner perspective what so what you've
been touching on there and here and
there but what what has been the journey
and growing the actual business head
camp wise I think that I love the fact
what you said Kevin around yeah you went
in tons of right now you look at all the
people in your business go yeah we want
all of them they all deliver value and I
think definitely I think right now I
think businesses that have maybe got
caught up in the sort of vanity of
headcount and all those sorts of things
that definitely have those realizations
right now aren't there so I guess what
what's been so what's been the sort of
headcount journey then so like when you
made that decision to go into utilities
and you had will really championing that
and going for it where was you then and
then they'll see how is it how has it
been and what have been the challenges
on that I think they had about probably
7 to 8 people about that time yeah yes I
think we the headcount thing is actually
this probably ties into also what what
you might do a bit differently although
I think when you're you know smaller
business you
we haven't got the ability to do this
but we've actually added quite a bit in
terms of non sale stuff so quite a few
of our hires have been from a
relationship manager to an Operations
Manager - no I know what stages you hire
those sorry because I think that's
really interested in probably within the
last last twelve probably 12 to 15
months okay let me look to wanting to
move the business forward yeah - kind of
touch on the poll point about getting
advice as a as a business leader and
getting some guidance around that think
about the classic thing about a lot of
people experience as billers in
recruitment and it's a classic thing you
get if you shoot a good bit of those
someone gives you a team leader job and
there's some people are just not cut out
for it
yeah and you know just because you're
just okay let's say you become a
recruitment I mean I fell into being a
manager and I did well in it but I tell
you what it was a baptism of fire and I
learn a lot along the way that does not
necessarily mean even if you run an
office for a massive recruitment company
you still got the loads of support
you've got all the back office you've
got all the finance sorted out you've
got training off of bizdev running your
own business does not mean you're going
to be a fantastic business business
leader just be good recruitment and I
think in terms of one thing that that's
helped us it's yeah getting the advice
in garments when someone's seen it but
also we would want to wear 50 hands each
every day yeah yeah you'd want to do
accounts you trying to do welfare you
want to do the holidays and actually
looking at what tasks are really
important for you to do in your role and
then looking at the other tasks got a
minute if I've hired someone for that it
might cost me X but how much what I make
I not folks here and half days a week
doing that so we've we've added quite a
bit to it in terms of we've had some
sales them to it we've got a couple of
clients where we've had to get some
account delivery you know candidate
delivery people into people focusing on
big accounts yeah and also a lot of
supportive roles so things like I said
like a relationship manager operations
manager compliance fee would you would
you would you have looking back again
cuz I think this is common quite a lot
would you would you have made those
hires earlier like if you could have do
you think like its position lot
operations manager or like yeah I think
we probably would have done I think one
of the things that this this pandemic is
allowed us to do is analyze for one
better phrase the ecosystem of our
business right now so when you're in the
wire back to January where jobs are
coming in and you're finding candidates
you're arranging interviews right before
you know it's Friday afternoon and your
governor I mean you've not even like
stopped to have lunch at any point
during the week you don't have time to
analyze what your business does and also
why your business does in so now we
we've been looking at the ecosystem
about our business and and trying to
ensure that not one consult is an island
because that becomes that becomes
dangerous then you know you we want to
know that every single person has an
integral part to play in the delivery of
the service that we give now that could
be you know from a marketing perspective
it could be from a BD perspective it
could be from a cameo generation
perspective but there's a unity that
exists within a business and we're far
from perfect and that needs to improve
so we've tweaked people's jobs because
sometimes we've tried to put a square
peg into a round hole and sometimes it
fits and you know you keep whacking away
at something I can eventually you get
there with it but actually with a bit of
with a bit of my time and consideration
you could tweak that person's job
slightly and there could be the best
version of that new role that exists in
the marketplace and they can still bring
in all that the wins and the business
that you would have liked them to do
during the previous job so I think the
ecosystem in our business has improved
and just hey that the the you know the I
suppose was a the jigsaw is that exactly
the same right we want to become the
leading provider of stuff within the
utilities and renewable space yeah but
the pieces of the jigsaw slightly
changed now so the image still looks
exactly the same that the goal is still
the same but what people bring to the
table is a bit different to what it was
even a week ago now so we're working the
key things you change them have
interests we have got someone focusing
purely on the market inside of our
business so we work with an SEO company
with new marketing fourth and then
they've been great and they've really
helped us develop our presence online
but we always say I say we always for
the last kind of six months we've said
we want to be the consultancy from next
week not last week so there's a lot of
dinosaurs out there
in industry and there's things that we
do you could put while you were dinosaur
because you do that yeah we've got me
we've got innovate we've got to embrace
every change that comes into the crew
business and acknowledge how that
benefits us our candidates and our
clients so we always want to be the
consultancy of next week
so we have a videographer that works
with us you know that's great but we
probably need someone in five days a
week not not three days a month
so we've trained up a marketing person
to do that we've lost the relations
we've got on how we service those and
the the various options we give our
clients whether that's from a billing
perspective from a delivery perspective
but also what I can sort of doing day in
day out and looked at more account
development and responsibilities as
opposed to here's a crime you never
spoke to go call them and tell them I
can sort any G because we've got enough
we've got enough clients currently but
it's about forming those relationships
well okay that's interesting so cool I
guess some how on hiring learnings just
just quickly before I move on someone
else like anything that you've changed
or implemented or done differently on
the hiring aspect that that's really
helped you get better at getting the
right people through the doors I think
that's obviously it's very ironic that
that's one of the biggest challenge yeah
and anything that you've changed or done
that people could benefit from maybe
that's really impacted your recruitment
process or getting the right people
through the door do you mean as internet
internally - yeah intern internally I
think I've seen this earlier in terms of
maybe making quick decisions but I think
some of those people I've probably
talked about generally it was a classic
scenario when we interviewed them we
thought yeah you know they seem pretty
good and actually we didn't have the
highest of high high standards you know
we put it through no they were never
decent and they get out they could do a
good job so we've really certainly set
our bar a bit higher because I don't
think anyone we've taken a punt on loads
of critics they can get someone in
they've got a bit of experience they're
willing they've phone they've build a
bit money they think you get them in but
actually you know I don't think anyone
we've taken pythons website look at that
across ten years yeah you know they
might have done some bits of business
you know you know sometimes
a broken watches right you know but
really turns on our business they've
they've been people that we had a good
feeling away from Stan so so don't be
scared to raise your standards
absolutely do that when you're looking
to hire yeah desperation you really want
to get people on board if once you make
the decision you want to push your
business forward needs for three or four
people
it's and sometimes you can go all
they're pretty good they look like
they'll probably you'll be all right
my advice would definitely be if you
think it's a don't do it and that's how
yeah so you've both mentioned speak
someone the the roadmap and the non exec
directs and stuff I think and be
interesting to get your forcement
experiences on that I've spoken to
number equipment business owners that
have had great experiences not so great
experiences and fun and a non exec I
guess what what how did you go about and
I think it's a really popular thing that
people do want and and want to have
access to and find people so I guess I
know rich you said there's a lot of
people out there and there are but what
what was the sort of genuine experience
and you guys finding someone that could
help consult energy move forward we we
got approached quite a number of years
ago by the recruiter entrepreneur okay
Jane James constant yeah and I think we
got kind of carried away with the bright
lights of it all and going down to the
Big Smoke and you know to two boys from
Birmingham being wanted by James Carney
and and that experience was brilliant
actually because it got us to ask some
really difficult questions about our
business that we tried to do that the
answers to so we had to understand how
we assess the MOT of our business and
and what not just tomorrow or next month
looks like what 12 months looks like so
the strategy around that and it got to a
point where they want it on board and
they wanted to you know give us a load
of cash it as a loan it turned out and
they were going to have a percentage of
our business and we just we we at that
point again realize that we could
probably get to where we wanted to get
to twice as quick with the support of
James Caan and he's in his recruitment
business and everyone we met through the
process was really impressive and really
talented but it meant giving away half
of our business just over half our
business so we thought well if it takes
us twice as long and we have twice as
much then
that's absolutely fine with us but we
met a couple of people along the way who
about 12 18 months later parted ways
we've recruited entrepreneur and reached
out to us and have ever since been a
while two of them started as a non exec
directors and for the last 15 months
which is what we've one of them and it's
been really interesting because we
didn't plan to get a non-executive
director it just you know it happened to
fall into our lap a little bit the one
thing that I've really benefited from is
the accountability yeah I was gonna say
what so how is it actually worked and is
it you have a once a meeting every
quarter and there's objectives and
there's things that you guys agree that
you're gonna do what like what's the
rules you might have specific things in
terms of certain consultants for
training you might want them to depends
what their level of expertise is rich
makes makes the plan exactly as a
recruitment over sometimes the only
person who can able to ease yourself as
yourself yeah so actually it's someone
holding your feet to the fire it's
really good as a as a business owner
because otherwise how would you even you
know know that you need to do so yeah
okay and then was there anything I guess
like is it anything that you was I know
it happened quite organically but was
this something that like really stood
out with this person or people that like
Jenai because I think some people like
words to start or like I want someone
that's sort of what the path that I want
to walk so it's that track record of
working with yeah and then we've
subsequently as we move forward now and
speaking to other people as well for us
it's looking at what they've done have
they've gone through a similar
experience and can they can they show a
track record of success with a business
like yours yeah that's what work
experience roles and recruitment but
yeah and and I guess I see so also the
benefit of that is that you don't have
to you don't have to give away over half
of your business
it's a you grow to have a relationship
with this person and they will know when
you know that it's it's not the right
movement for your business so they you
know you can't just not one size fits
all policy
and the one thing that we've really
benefit from is we would happily live in
the weeds on a day to day basis but you
need someone's go right let's let's go
over here look at the strategy and where
is he I guess even having that dedicated
time is so valuable to know I mean
especially with a business where you're
at and where you're grow and as you're
growing just having that dedicated time
because we're known if you didn't have
that when would you begin that time to
go right careful let's go down pub and
think about this or not yeah yeah
totally yeah throughout the time of us
having non-executive directors we've
grown our business 100% we've opened up
a u.s. operation we've promoted people
we've improved our internal recruitment
process we've created and really like
efficient and strong back-office
function and we've actually created
various different other schemes for want
of a better phrase within the energy
sector that aren't to do with
recruitment but give us a real presence
in the marketplace now some of them have
come directly from you know Ned saying
you should do it and others have come
from them asking us questions and
answers about yeah yeah yeah
so when do you think to sort of wrap up
then I guess when when do you think
people should consider reaching out to
people to have that sort of relationship
a lifestyle type business and you've got
key clients and it's working okay then
maybe some great yeah objectives are
yeah the minute you decide you want to
take it as I take it seriously you might
if you want to push it forward and scour
your business and then there's probably
it's probably a good point to even have
an exposure conversation with someone I
think people will often even just tell
you about what they can offer and then
it's a choice isn't it I don't think
even they need to think it's necessarily
going to be quite an expensive thing
yeah okay and let's talk him let's talk
a bit about today then and what's been
going on I guess what so I know we've
sort of touched on that but what what
have you got what's been the most
challenging part or challenge a decision
you've had to make over the last eight
weeks
Kevin touched on something something
earlier about you know when you go into
or when companies have gone into into
this pandemic they've got rid of a lot
of stuff
and communism use it as a reason to get
rid of people and companies that have
done it and then we are nice about
furlough or perhaps some of them are
back tracks and put people on furlough
others haven't I think what we've
learned through this is that we we've
got staff members that we want to keep
then Kevin licensed it to everyone and
we'll do all we can to ensure that what
we look like when we return stuff
numbers-wise is exactly the same as what
we look like when we left you know when
when they started I've learned the low
register in jail actually might be more
than more than when we started
definitely will be more than one we've
got a guy starting on the 1st of June
doing the US business with with will and
and Edie yeah I think it's if you have
you had to had a knee if you had to have
any grown up team conversations about
hey guys look we're all in this together
so this means to give us the best
possible chance getting through this
let's take well yeah yeah well we did
well yeah and everyone's gonna suffer a
little bit rather than someone's
suffering a lot yeah and we've reduced
the hours quite quickly to 80% so we did
four days over five okay and then we had
to make decision on who to furlough and
you know they were difficult decisions
because everybody wants to help
everybody wants to be there and you know
be trying to push the business back to
survival oh yes yeah play their part
everyone has a plan yeah yeah and it's a
difficult mental challenge for people
sometimes I'm envious sometimes I'd like
spend a couple days in the garden but
I'm wired to want to be there do me I
can't to help things move forward and we
quite quickly came up with it a survive
and we stole this from but survived
revive and thrive phase okay I think a
lot of people are thinking we're gonna
sit here it's all [ __ ] we're gonna get a
phone call Friday afternoon and life
will be back to normal on Monday and
then it will thrive and it's not just
nothing happens room yeah we've got a
revive period in the middle that slowly
eases us back to where we want to get to
and one of those one of those
responsibilities during that revived
phase is to bring another member of
staff on to the u.s. business because
that market is moving there quicker than
the UK market
and we also need to map out what thrive
looks like during their life to even be
in a position where we can look back in
12 months ago we absolutely maximize
that opportunity you know in every
crisis is opportunity and I think we
know we can't change the channel right
warning in listener we're in the same
boat but we're all definitely the same
storm and we'll be fine just like when
we start out recruiting business and we
thought oh [ __ ]
we don't have finance we don't have a
chart we've only got to that something
too far we backed ourselves we still
back ourselves it's a commodities with a
team of driven individuals and now
probably bought more into us as a
business because of how we treat them
away yeah how um what how have you gone
about getting the this person to join
they're not of interest like what was
what was the interview process like what
what was their first week and like how
have you got this like have they already
met you guys had they already been
bought in one day yes so so it was
almost a final stage of the process and
he got one hold a little bit because we
didn't know what it's not like yeah I
had one different conversation that I
haven't mentioned we had someone who's
making as a start and we had to we had
to postpone or postpone their start and
we don't even know when that because you
just don't know what remote onboarding
looks like you don't know what you know
but fortunately this guy that's done in
the US has got five years of cantilever
experience he is using the time to get
up to speed with the spirit it's going
to recruit for to actually it's not it's
not someone eyes you'd have to try it
train up and there be an element of
training but you know I mean yeah so
which helps with that however keV have
you found I think that one of the
biggest challenges the billing leaders
have had current businesses have had
this mate how have you been motivating
your team but how have you found that
yeah this is very good question actually
in terms of some of the trickier things
let's be honest in expectations wise
people probably aren't gonna do the same
level of business because there's not
there but I think if you if you write
little too hard and expect too much from
them that can obviously have a
demotivating factor as well so it's that
real fine balance between getting
everyone to be the best version of so
they can be yeah and to give it all
they've got when actually they might be
dealing with you know who knows what at
home you know people I'm got you know
the people that work for us I've got
five members up phone Amazon well at
home some like rich and I've got kids
and you know God you know I know you see
everything you know on LinkedIn and
Facebook about people are dealing with
home working but we all know if you've
got children that you can have a morning
which can just get written off because
some animals you know it's it's that
sense for me that I want everyone to be
giving it all they've got on the same
token not you know not only stressing
himself what key expectations we changed
out of interest so some of the things
that have come out of it so yesterday
was it's really really was you hear the
advice of the tongue and focus on the
only things you can control
right control the controllables and and
her name was Rihanna and she's a
building manager and what their how they
change their expectations and KPI
slightly was they've made sure that they
really focused on the things that they
may be up slightly but are all things
that they can control yeah I mean that's
really interesting we've always had a
real manner of effect where you can
affect you know this yeah since the
early stages of my recruitment career
you know so three or four sort of buzz
buzz phrase I'd like to use so with what
we do the key thing we change was sort
of all of our KPIs we just said to
everyone right a little bit of safety
now is element that's it give us a deal
em up at the moment and and the initial
crisis we'll be happy with that of
course we've got guidance on KPIs and
what we've actually done is in terms of
things like video calls and video
messages things like that I think our
expectations are that people probably
gonna be easy to get all of in some
situations because everyone's at home
but also the people probably gonna get a
bit of fatigue from doing video calls
all day so you know you've got to look
at actually locally what what's what
issues might be but we're not in the
same situation where we expect the same
level of activity but we just expect
people to be to be to give it all
they've got and we've said to an element
yeah and what what's what does them
what's a typical week that like so far
you guys you guys I guess also you got
your leaders beneath your stuff but what
have you done to make sure that you're
touching base with people how much touch
points you having with people medical
furlough not on furlough what's that
look like so far what we do it we do a
morning call
anyone can be involved in our man sort
of furlough people on on it that's to
talk about the day and what the
expectations are there more some pledges
what we're going to do each day they
will there'll be a capture call Utley
and all are all video calls to talk
about what successes you've had and then
we try and get some information item one
about the positives in the business yeah
one thing I think we've done pretty well
he's actually been sharing good news
because we've had some feedback from
people on furlough there's actually
great to hear that's yeah yeah they're
so great here yeah going well we've had
a bit of a plan in terms of catching up
with furlough people so they feel like
there's a bit of connection we've been
doing a weekly quiz which is going
really well although I'm a bit good
about that because I'm basically the
winner supposed to do the next quiz I'm
I won one one week I was too busy to do
the quiz so I got someone else to do it
and those ran on the Kardashians and
around on Harry Potter and I just don't
you know I'm never gonna win the quiz
again though so but basically the quiz
when it gets like you know 20-pounder
spend on like people meet someone just
trying to sort of do things to keep
people interact in interacted there's a
little thing cooking with consult so you
know what points to one social media
right you know different recipes and
busy and okay yeah just trying to keep
people at least connected in some way
yeah cool and what was gonna say yeah I
think what someone that came out with
the log podcaster did yesterday was like
like obviously a lot of questions came
in and like how you were in how are you
incentivizing your team or so typically
you've got the things like classic lunch
clubs and the holidays and all that
right also you move right now they're
not things you can do but actually the
the actual rule incentive here for teams
that are close-knit that are in this
together the biggest incentive is
getting through it and getting together
to not I mean and I think that's such a
thing hopefully things you can look back
and be proud of your team during this
and I think that's a great thing to look
back on
I guess look you guys have been in
industry a while much longer than I have
people want to know what what the
people's thoughts on what this looks
like and we start coming back out this
from a recruiting standpoint what are
your thoughts on I guess things that
might stick around and and really impact
your recruitment business when we start
coming back out of this like what are
your thoughts on how your recruitment
business may change or the industry may
change I think Abby's
well then the main change will be the
time spent in the office okay the
flexibility to allow people to wash your
view before was it we want you in the
office
we actually about a polybag Yeon are two
years ago we brought a bit of work from
home in okay you know I know it's easy
to say that we've we have tried to be a
bit bit innovative even though sometimes
you feel like your final yeah we've done
that for people I think you know we felt
like back in the day when we all got
into recruitment it was a case if you
know if you had a doctor's appointment
oh my god that's that you know you know
so we've looked at a situation where
honest someone's having a washing
machine delivered what everybody said
just work from home for the day all got
a meeting or even today I need a day and
I think that's definitely was on our
radar but it I think it'll just be on my
radar a bit more yeah you know and as
opposed to be maybe a couple times a
month it might be you might be weekly is
it gonna is it gonna affect how you
think and consider a lot of bencher
office obviously like does it make you
think twice about the office space what
you'd want to do that I don't know yeah
I think so our plan our office that
we're in at the moment we're not a
meeting room I can probably hold it you
know
25 26 people yeah and then we're going
to leave
I know thing you know Kevin I spoke
about this with you working from home
and okay but not who knows when you can
have my desk again because that's one of
the things that you know you can't do
but without working from home in that 25
full-time people might actually end up
being 40 people yeah everyone's always
gonna be in the office at the same time
so I think he'll have a massive impact
on the amount of space that people
require yeah in recruit many Wayne and
the people that we've spoken to in our
network so probably thinking that the
same as well because it's hard at the
moment right working from home and in
the past has been seen as a bit of a
luxury and it's always been a choice if
you if you've been given it know people
want to get back into the office and you
don't have the choice to work in the
office at the moment so when people can
go in the office and work from home I
think that freedom of movement that
flexibility will really benefit our
staff members know my my eldest is going
to scored in September and the schools
around the corner and if I work the
hours are normally work which I get in
the office for
and I work till 4:00 I won't be able to
drop her off yeah but I'll definitely
we'll do that night with working
remember a couple of times a week
because you know like that largest
disappears and things could happen
we've had some chemistry we've had staff
members have had terrible news either
last couple of months and it makes you
realize is that you can get so consumed
sometimes in your profession and you and
your life and you can be so busy earning
a career that you forget about all the
other things outside of it yeah
difficult you've been working from home
is where you draw that line where do you
shove a laptop or clothes at all yeah my
biggest challenge yeah it's it's harder
than I think we you know you just
stretch it when you've got obviously
some like me more so like don't have a
dedicated workspace and yeah I mean like
not everyone's gonna have that info are
their policy and people will want to
adjust and work if them home isn't
necessarily sitting in a bedroom and
then up top you might going to you know
coffee house they saw me doing that
scene sitting a park on a nice day and
make some phone calls
you know for us Kevin touched on it you
know we want people to try and achieve a
tournament and what I think we'll focus
on more after this is just the
productivity that people bring and it
will guide them will direct them or give
them you know ideas around if you do X
you're gonna get Y but we're also going
to give people the freedom to do what
they're really good at more and you know
you know make their own mistakes every
now and then and and know from that and
hopefully that puts us in a position
where we come out of this and there's
more glue in our business because yeah
we do have those catch ups during the
day but also what does happen that Kevin
I don't see is all of our stuff we talk
to each other like they do video calls
and grabbing a coffee during the day so
they give a [ __ ] about each other we
know that would only intensify because
of this and you know what will come out
of it and our environment will be
stronger I you it you'll be stronger and
then that becomes a really exciting
prospect for someone coming into yeah I
think there are challenges also with the
whole work from home II it sounds
brewery in principle but if you decided
to start a new team you needed three
three new new recruiters in terms of you
know the dynamism and and getting our
team
that's all you said at the beginning
Kevin review Gardens progressive and
sort of being catapulted into that
environment the people and its osmosis
isn't it when you're around those people
and that's that is 100% that's the
biggest challenge isn't it how do you
create that and is that possible when
you've got three new people on the team
and like that you need that that's so
valuable that early isn't it and it's
not always that easy to do it
retrospectively ie you know I've got a
call what shall I say we need in a
recruitment office as I remember to
progress em on a phone call and if
someone's on here go in say this and
actually you know that that's that's the
live situation the pitch is like
someone's back to play a game of
football
what you need to do today in the game is
this as opposed to on the pitch peanuts
affected yeah totally so as we come to
the end chapter two last questions for
you first one rich om come to you first
what what are you most excited about to
do what you're most excited to do or
experience or want to do when we come
out of kovat postcodes what you're most
excited about them he's all right when
you get to 30 a there's not a lot that
kind of like makes you family decide you
know I want to have a mom and dad and I
want to then spend time with the girls
and you know I want to I want to be in
an environment where I can just go wow
this is over now whether that's a busy
pub where that's a night I would friends
whatever it might be one of the things
I'm supposed to care about this year of
the day one of them I'm looking forward
to so we've got season to get the villa
for lessons and you know we're not a
very good football team at the moment
but we we do a bit of hospitality so we
take client success yeah and the feeling
that I get when I walk out to Villa Park
and just take it all in it's a
my dad took me when I was like seven or
six so I'm fairly you getting you all
downstairs on Christmas Day for me would
tell me that because there'll be 40,000
fans in a stadium yeah feeling you know
he still brings up the hairs on the back
of my neck so that's definitely what
away from keV all about you mate yeah
the Sun is sort of things seen family
and friends I just think having a sense
of there's a lot of people out there
that are are paused even though they're
trying to keep it going the sense of
people would be able to get back to just
just to be themselves yeah that
spontaneity as well you know I mean um
you know it's quite funny isn't it you
know anyone that that knows rich knows
that he's he's a keen runner and I've
really got into in the last in the last
five weeks I can't play football I can't
go to the gym but that's kind of the
limit of what I can do you know just
been out to go out go out for the day
somewhere you have that someone tonight
early doing something awful
I need a boy sweets go to the shops so I
just think getting a bit of normality
back in terms of doing stuff I'm the
same as richer and they I get really
really kept busy by my kids and you know
probably quite a nice tavern line with
my other half and you know yeah so I'll
come back to you have lost final
question always ask people who seek an
answer this with a phrase or word the
sentence whatever comes up for you but
if you could communicate to every single
recruits out there they'd listen to
advice that implements it had action it
tomorrow what what would you say to the
people yeah any level just what yeah so
my advice to anybody would be don't get
to one of the any of you recruitment
career whatever that is and look back
and think ah I wish I'd just you know
instead I just think the opportunity to
Nick that phrase from that song but the
time is now and in every situation you
know I just think you've got to be
effective what you can expect and the
other thing I'd say is I've learnt this
throughout my life both for me they
might my my only 12 years living in
Birmingham you know in a council flat
and stuff to do early years in
recruitment when it wasn't work
for me is the only person it's gonna
save yourself yeah I love that so I just
think that actually you know all about
that self analysis if it isn't working
for you for whatever reason take a step
back and look at what you've done is my
client strategy good enough don't know
enough about my business can I pitch my
company in 30 seconds do I know enough
candidates am I good enough at using the
database how am I collect make it feel
good enough I just think they're in a
situation right now the best recruiters
and if you're a good recruit you're
gonna make a lot of money another great
career all the ones that are on top of
the game you know on top you game I
think you need to just assess it and
trend it up mmm awesome I love that rich
it's interesting I'm watching a lot of
people on the last dance document
Michael Julius they're so good and it's
just like it's it's its immense right
the thing that I'm taking from it is he
always backs himself yeah and even the
littlest of things like one of the guys
being on the golf course and then
regretted straightaway yeah get the best
of Mike Jordan on the court the next day
and I think it is that right you've got
back yourself you've got have a real
belief you have got the talent what
people forget about Michael Jordan is
that you'll see that the glitz and the
glamour in the awards but you don't see
him put in all the effort in yeah all
the training and what we do it's a
contact sport you've got a contact
people however you contact them whether
it's on the phone whether it's via
social media whether it's in sending
letters oh whatever it might be it's a
context for us you can't forget that but
you need to have a plan because if you
don't have a strategy and a plan about
what you want to achieve then you have
no long-term success in recruitment in
my opinion you have short term wins you
can you know you can accidentally
contact or the right person just at the
right time but you've got except that
it's it's a contact sport you've got to
trust the process so not necessarily the
outcome and you've gotta trust the
promises and that might mean looking to
someone with experience to get what that
process is or that strategy but know
that you get what you put in so if you
have the right plan you've got the right
guidance then after that it's a contact
sport so whether it's a post that gets
20,000 views or it's one phone call to
the right hiring manager
because you know it's the my hiring
manager now you've got to be conscious
of where you're where you're utilizing
your energy so plan for it and then work
like work like and this is why I was a
consultant right to start I had an image
of a consultant in another office that
just wanted to beat me never been
bothered you know and perhaps this is
why I kept doing team commission for so
long what people pay me doesn't bother
me is whether I feel that that that
winning side so there was always a
consultant in another office that was
always gonna do more than me and that
was my competition so I think you know
that doesn't change no matter how many
likes posts get or how many views a
video has you still got a contact people
sort of get on the phone and fill that
person or fill one of those views I need
a list of people they're going to do
business with you so plan for it and
then like lose your mind going for it
yeah the other thing I'd add as well he
said read daily Goggins book I'm at yeah
Jesus Christ there's some good some of
my runs lately up in I've had him in my
head as I'm trying to stop on my own
yeah baby I'm thinking around you man on
two broken legs with a homeless heart be
quiet
have you listened to the audiobook in my
ears as I'm trying to augment yeah yeah
if anyone here you have to listen to
audio beside the best audio and blow
rich keV been an absolute pleasure Thank
You enriched Lance it's awesome Frank
station